foreign
[Music]
if then in the picture thinking
Consciousness the inwardizing of natural
self-consciousness was the real
existence of evil that inwardizing in
the element of self-consciousness is the
knowledge of evil as something that is
implicit in existence
this knowledge is of course a Genesis of
evil but only a Genesis of the thought
of evil and is therefore recognized as
the first moment of reconciliation
for as a withdrawal into itself from the
immediacy of nature which is determined
as evil it is a forsaking of that
immediacy and a dying away of sin it is
not natural existence as such that is
forsaken by Consciousness but natural
existence that is at the same time known
as evil the immediate movement of
withdrawal into self is just as much a
mediated movement it presupposes itself
or is its own ground that is to say the
ground of the withdrawal into self is
that nature has already withdrawn into
itself on account of evil man must
withdraw into himself but evil is itself
the withdrawal into self
this first movement is for that very
reason only immediate or the simple
notion of that movement because it is
the same as what its ground is
the movement or other ring has therefore
still to appear but in its own more
characteristic form
in paragraph 783 which is fairly short
there's some very interesting
contrasts or distinctions that are going
on here as well as transitions movements
but vegan right that are happening here
in the the text as we approach the end
of the religion section and the
culmination of all of this laborious
dialectical work so he says that
if then in the picture thinking
Consciousness The Voice sign that is
using for Stalin right for stellengen
picture thinking which we've talked a
lot about the inwardizing of natural
self-consciousness was the real
existence of evil that inwardizing in
the element of self-consciousness is the
knowledge of evil as something that is
implicit in existence so a lot going on
there just in that first sentence and we
see that what we've got here is a number
of different contrasts so picture
thinking Consciousness another kind of
Consciousness self-consciousness and
what we have to read in here is this
Universal self-consciousness where
self-consciousness is related to its
other
and it's being found in the community
and he does use the term element there
right so we've got a contrast between
two different points of view we have a
connection on this inwardizing inner
leak verden Verdin to become right
uh inwardizing works for that to become
literally something that is inward
interleak right to go from the exterior
to the interior to become more in the
interior and we've got inwardizing here
which could be understood as being the
inwardizing of natural
self-consciousness right it would make
sense since it's going to come up uh in
just a little bit but here it's very
explicit the inwardizing of natural
self-consciousness the
self-consciousness that knows itself as
an individual as something embodied in
the world and then we have of evil Bursa
showing up in two different ways and
we'd be tempted to think well the most
important way is the real existence
there is the adjective dazine right of
of evil and okay we can even leave off
real existence because real isn't doing
any work there in the translation
but then we have the knowledge of evil
as such all zulk right and so knowledge
is in a way more important than just
mere existence right especially from a
idealist perspective
and then we get something even more
interesting here knowledge of evil as
such right so now we're actually getting
to what is evil
as implicit on Z right in itself
in existence so it's not just existing
evil or evil in existence it's evil as
implicit as right there in what
existence gives us so where do we go
from here then he says well this
knowledge is of course and here we get
the first you could say reference to
something almost performative
performative in the sense of something
by doing something saying something
thinking something makes something
happen not just like putting on air is
performative as people uh sometimes
interpret that world so this knowledge
he says is of course a Genesis a coming
into being a virgin right of evil but
only a Genesis of the thought of evil
and it is therefore recognized as the
first moment of
reconciliation something that we're
aiming at by the end of this and you
know going to see develop yet more once
we move past religion and to Absolute
knowing
reconciliation within the community
so he goes on and he says as a
withdrawal into itself a withdrawal into
itself is
going back into something and what can
it go into well it could go back into
the world but it's actually withdrawing
retreating from the world you could say
a withdrawal into itself from
the immediacy and mitsalbachite of
nature which is determined as evil it is
a forsaking of that immediacy in a dying
away of sin now we've got to be a little
bit careful here is this a withdrawal
into itself away from
the entire natural world no because the
natural world itself is not evil it's
the humanized natural world where humans
can realize themselves as evil and so
what do we get we get a forsaking a fair
Lawson and it's interesting because the
German here is Das Elba so forsaking of
itself and Miller translates that here
as a forsaking of that immediacy
immediacy of nature
now in a certain way that's the wrong
translation in a certain way it's a
revealing translation a forsaking of the
you know nature that is the nature of
the human being the damaged selfish
individualized nature having a body
having desires all those sorts of things
and then a dying away
you know dying uh in the opposite
direction you could say to sin zunda so
this is how it's overcoming evil and
then he goes on and he says it's not
natural existence as such forsaken by
Consciousness right so it's not even the
fact that we say have to eat for example
it's the fact that we have to eat and
that involves us in a certain way with
evil we you know we could be vegans and
be like oh I don't eat the plants well
you're still eating the plants you think
the plants want to get eaten up no they
don't and if you're a vegan of course I
mean this is a whole other conversation
but you're you're it's not as if you're
not complicit in animal cruelty because
all those vegetables that you're eating
had to be raised in fields where the
plows were chopping up the poor little
earthworms and shrews and pesticides
might have been used oh it could have
been organic yes but even organic things
are designed to keep away pests and you
know to to eliminate them from the
fields we can go on and on and on
anything that's distinctively human
can be realized not just as good
but is involving Us in evil natural
existence that is at the same time known
as evil
so he goes on the knee tracks here we
have the withdrawal into self the duruk
Gan and now we have the withdrawal into
self here that is a different term in
Zeke and one that we've encountered many
times right in this religion section so
the being that withdraws into itself it
goes into itself is involved at the same
time with an immediate movement and a
mediated movement right
so he goes on and he says uh here we go
the immediate movement of withdrawal
into self is just as much a mediated
movement
how is it a mediated movement I mean
every movement is
strictly speaking a mediated movement
there is nothing that is purely
immediate within the hegelian framework
but how is it immediate here
he says to us it presupposes itself
or it is its own ground wound Foundation
so this is a very interesting you know
again we see this uh uh by doing
something it becomes something right by
preoccupying itself with evil it shows
itself as being involved with evil it is
its own ground right and so he says that
that is to say the ground of the
withdrawal into self the ground of this
movement
is that nature has already withdrawn
into itself on account of evil man must
withdraw into himself so that's one side
but evil is itself the withdrawal into
self so by trying to escape the evil we
become evil we become more conscious of
the evil that we cannot escape from
extricate ourselves from because the
very fact of trying to do that has put
us back into the knowledge of evil a
knowledge that is not an evil is out
there
but within ourselves and at the same
time we can have this recognition that
we need to die to it we need to reject
it we need to go away from it and so he
says this first movement is for that
very reason only immediate or the simple
notion the begaf right the concept of
that movement because it is the same as
what its ground is having its own ground
being its own ground is not something
that's an advance it's actually a defect
it's something circular that needs to be
expanded and broken and then put back
together so he says the movement or
other ring
therefore still has to appear but
in its own more characteristic form what
does this imply
that we have not in this yet attained
its own characteristic form but we've
made some progress here in this
paragraph
besides this immediacy therefore the
mediation of the picture thought is
necessary the knowledge of nature as the
untrue existence of spirit and this
imminently developed universality of the
self is in itself the reconciliation of
spirit with itself
for the self-consciousness that does not
think in terms of the notion this in
itself receives the form of something
that possesses immediate being and is
imaginatively represented comprehension
is therefore for that self-consciousness
not a grasping of this notion which
knows superseded natural existence to be
Universal and therefore reconciled with
itself but rather a grasping of the
imaginative idea that by bringing to
pass its own externalization in its
historical Incarnation and death the
Divine being has been reconciled with
its natural existence
the grasping of this idea now expresses
more definitively what was previously
called the spiritual Resurrection in
this same context the coming into
existence of God's individual
self-consciousness as a universal
self-consciousness or as the religious
community the death of the Divine man as
death is abstract negativity the
immediate results of the movement which
ends only in natural universality
death loses this natural meaning in
spiritual self-consciousness that is
comes to be its just stated notion Death
Becomes transfigured from its immediate
meaning that is the non-being of this
particular individual into the
universality of the spirit who dwells in
his community dies in it every day and
is daily Resurrected
in paragraph 784 we're following along
the trajectory that has been outlined
we're engaging with the death of the god
man the Incarnate God within the
community and we're looking at two
different ways of attaining perspective
or to use the word that Hegel is going
to have to comprehend or to grasp a lot
of concept and grabbing terminology
coming up here including Eric hyphen
which gets used a lot uh you know to
latch onto to to grasp and then of
course the concept or the notion the if
and whether something is
engaging in conceptual thought or
whether it's by contrast working with
images representations pictures right so
what we're really talking about here is
a phrase that he uses
um and he's going to talk about the
knowledge of nature as the untrue
existence of spirit and this imminently
developed universality of the self
being in itself what the reconciliation
the first winning of spirit with itself
which is really what the whole
phenomenology
is about even though it doesn't say so
at every point of course but it but it's
what it's aiming for and the
phenomenology is supposed to be kind of
a record of how at least for some people
Consciousness Spirits has already done
this Hegel is not providing us with the
as he views it path forward that you
know leads to some
utopian land that none of us have ever
seen it's it's happened already within a
certain understanding according to Hegel
of Christianity and its traditional for
Stelling and it's it's representations
it's dogmas you might say so he tells us
besides this immediacy what immediacy
the immediacy that we encountered in the
previous uh paragraph the immediacy of
nature the immediate the mediation of
picture thought is necessary no vending
it it's needed still at this stage at
this point why this is where that
sentence occurs the knowledge of nature
the vision of nature as untrue Untold
right existence of spirit and this
imminently developed universality of the
self that's the reconciliation how does
this work so he says for the
self-consciousness that does not think
in terms of the notion the
self-consciousness that is uh
unconceptual you can say
um he says this in itself this anzique
receives the form of something that has
two important characteristics here one
is that both of these are a little bit
longer translations it possesses
immediate being
in the German it's just I designed it it
it's something that has being it's
something that is right it's not very
developed or anything like that
immediate being okay that works and is
imaginatively represented and it's
forgerstone right something that is
pictured something represented
imagination is certainly doing some work
here as a faculty that's perfectly fine
so then he goes on and he talks about
what is possible for this and here we
have a parting of the ways right
comprehension
now notice right because
the act of engaging in
conceptualizing comprehending
can go one of two ways
it could if we were on the ball right
there
um it could get us to this stuff
comprehension is that is for that
self-consciousness
not a grasping of this notion
of the biggest right a
grasping of what is graspable you know
wrapping our head around something it's
not that and what would it be he says
it's not a grasping of this notion which
knows
superseded alcohol business natural
existence to be Universal and therefore
reconciled with itself wouldn't that be
nice if we could grasp that instead we
settle for second best here and he says
that instead what we get is uh here we
go the grasping of the imaginative idea
the imaginative ideas just for Stellar
right so instead of grasping the concept
it graphs the uh
second best not quite as good can't make
you know reflexive use of itself for
styling for stolen's not bad though
right let's remind ourselves of this
Force drawing is great it allows us to
advance as he just said earlier it's
note vending it's necessary we we do
have to go through that
it's just not all there is right so he
goes on and says here we go
um grasping of the imaginative idea that
by bringing to pass its own
externalization so
what do we have here this is a narrative
that is being provided that's supposed
to have meaning through bringing to pass
now the bringing to pass dasca Shan
Through The Happening you could also say
of this it's not quite so agency
oriented bringing to pass its own
externalization and oy song right and
here he's actually going to be using a
word that the Miller translation only
brings up a little bit later Divine
being gold leak of vase and right the
goately conveys and the Divine being is
what is externalizing itself so
it uh externalizes itself in what
historical Incarnation mentioned Verda
literally becoming human and it's death
the you know crucifixion the atonement
you could say right so this is Christ
this is this is the Christ story about
God for whatever reason uh you know the
second person of the Trinity the son
becoming human and uh dying for all of
us now what he says there is that the
Divine being the gold leak of Eason is
now reconciled with its existence it's
Dawson and Miller adds in Brackets
natural existence
ah that that works I don't think that he
he needs to insist on it there as he
kind of seems to be doing but he goes on
and he tells us
um
that the coming there we go uh it's been
reconciled with its natural existence
the grasping of this idea now expresses
more definitely what was previously
called the spiritual Resurrection in the
same context so what is that the coming
into existence of God's individual
self-consciousness as a universal
self-consciousness or as the religious
community so that is what's going on in
the background the question is how is
that religious community
understanding itself in relation to the
Divine being which is becoming human and
allowing itself to die how does this
actually work is it primarily through
this figure of the Christ when you think
about going into a church and seeing a
crucifix with not just a cross but
actually the body the Corpus hung on
there sometimes with you know know many
wounds and blood and lacerations
depicted what is that supposed to be
doing it's reaffirming as you walk in
that hey this is what this is supposed
to be about right I think a lot of uh
Christians is a bit of a side note could
really benefit from spending a little
bit of time when they come into a church
actually looking up there and thinking
about that guy and what it is that he
stood for and represented and taught to
people because much of the time they
they lose the threat a little bit it
becomes about togetherness it becomes
about culture War it becomes about this
and that all these things that really
don't have much to do with Christianity
understood as centered in Christ right
so aside over let's come back to this he
goes on and he says that um
the death of the Divine man as death
right so the death of the Divine man is
death is abstract negativity now
negativity is usually a pretty good
thing in a hegelian perspective right it
gives us openness it gives us movement
merely abstract negativity is not all
that helpful to make a little pun here
we could say that it's a bit of a dead
end right uh there's not going to be a
lot of development he says the immediate
result of the movement which ends only
in
natural
universality right and what is natural
universality well I think we could say
in this context one way of understanding
it is hey we're all going to die that's
going to come for all of us
we all have Horizons right everybody's
going to either die before us or after
us or at the same time that's not
something we can really do that much
with in this case
but
we can transform that
the meaning of death can be something
different and here's where we get to the
importance of spirit as the community
which is where Hegel wants to take us
through the rest of this religion
section
it's not that we have to abandon
completely The Narrative the depictions
the picture thinking the imaginative
exercises that people do
um but we're supposed to go on to
something more
so he tells us
death loses this natural meaning in
spiritual
self-consciousness spiritual
self-consciousness is where
Consciousness that is grasping the
notion could have gone will go but
hasn't quite gone yet hegel's
prefiguring for us where we can go death
loses its natural meaning and spiritual
self-consciousness that is
it comes to be it's just stated notion
it develops into its notion right Death
Becomes transfigured from its immediate
meaning that is the non-being of this
particular individual Jesus Christ or
you know any one of us
into the meaning that it has for the
community the universality of the spirit
who is Hegel says dwells in his
community I mean this is a little bit of
a side note as well but think about this
one way of understanding what Hegel is
saying here is that God is too big to
dwell in just one single human person
however you know privileged or blessed
they may be God needs to be in a
community of
comprised of persons who aren't all just
individuals put together in one sort of
aggregate their self-consciousness they
exist in relation to each other as well
as in relation to and through the divine
so that can only happen in community it
could be a virtual community to some
degree right if you think about
religious organizations they are not
just about who's present right there but
are understood to be you know part of a
larger Community you know the church uh
the uh the nation the song you know
whatever it's going to be right and it
extends backwards into time and forward
into time as well so what happens there
what does death look like in this
community where spirit is reconciled to
itself
spirit
dies
in it every day and his daily
resurrected dying isn't just a one-time
Affair of this guy on the cross in
Palestine it is something that is
continually happening within the
community a cyclical
cycloidal growing upon itself sort of
thing that Hegel thinks is what what
Christianity reveals itself to the
phenomenologist as being genuinely about
when we grasp it in its notion rather
than just through representations or
imaginations